this video is sponsored by squarespace
come on there it goes one two three
let's do this it's 2004
the super bowl jessica simpson just
announced the beginning of the halftime
show
the show starts with janet jackson and
then nelly
and his crew riding out on a red truck
to sing a song about it being very hot
in here
and telling women to
then puff daddy or pee diddy or just
diddy i guess or sean comes or whatever
you want to call him and then the finale
of the halftime show
back to janet jackson but this time in
the final moments of this whole big
show superstar justin timberlake comes
onto stage
him and janet jackson perform one of
timberlake's most popular songs
rock your body the final line of that
song says
quote bet i'll have you naked by the end
of this song it feels really weird to
say that in quotes
anyway as that last line approaches
justin timberlake moves close to janet
jackson
to prepare for that final line and then
this happens
okay hold on instant replay and yes i'm
blurring this
because i have to it's youtube and i
just have to blur this moment
justin timberlake reaches over and pulls
the breast cup of janet jackson's shirt
ripping it off to reveal her breast for
just over
a half a second to an audience of
millions of people
this moment was a spark that lit
a wildfire was it planned
tell us exactly what happened
last week shameful halftime display
we love giving y'all something to talk
about
publicity stunt okay i was really young
when this all happened
but i have been deep in it reading like
newspapers and stuff
from that time and i didn't realize that
this
half a second of exposed breasts became
an inflection point in tv and internet
history in american history suddenly the
whole world wanted to talk about it to
scrutinize
it to find out what happened and why
who's to blame the founder of youtube
actually said in an interview that one
of the reasons he started youtube
was because of this moment because so
many people wanted to re-watch
a video of what went down and they
couldn't find it because back then there
was no
youtube there's no facebook there was no
twitter so he literally invented youtube
to like solve the problem people wanted
to see this to scrutinize it to look at
it
the internet searches for janet jackson
went bonkers
there was such a massive influx of
people searching
the internet that janet's web page which
back then was just like a
fan page crashed like if you go back to
look at the archives
of the internet there's just like a
black spot in the days after the
super bowl because literally there was
so much traffic that it just crashed the
site
janet jackson was under this microscope
everybody
wanted to have an opinion the whole
thing spurred a debate
about how families should be able to
watch the super bowl without being
exposed to lewd
sexually provocative content
[Music]
no no no not that stuff that's fine
there was a boob
a real life boob for a half a second on
tv
that's what we're talking about stay
focused the white house issued a
statement on the topic
congress had a hearing about this the
fcc
which is the place that regulates
broadcasters here in the us launched an
investigation into whether or not
cbs who like broadcasts the super bowl
was in on it last week's shameful
halftime display
at the super bowl you knew it was going
to happen right you didn't know it was
going to happen
no i didn't you didn't know what was
going to happen janet jackson's
explanation for this whole thing is that
it was a stunt but it
went wrong it went too far it was
supposed to kind of happen like that but
what actually happened wasn't
i wasn't supposed to come out of it the
way that i did janet said that what was
supposed to happen
is that justin timberlake rips this off
and there was supposed to be like a bra
underneath and it was supposed to be
kind of
provocative but not like full breast it
was very embarrassing for me to have so
many people see
but people didn't believe this with the
media discussion
and the congressional hearing and the
fcc investigation people started to make
their own opinions about what they
believed
actually happened and who was deployed
tonight janet jackson is apologizing for
her flash dance a last-minute stunt that
went too far
the chairman of the fcc concluded quote
clearly
somebody had knowledge of it clearly it
was something that was planned by
someone he said and then he said quote
she probably got what she was looking
for referring specifically to janet
jackson so the fcc
finds cbs for like a half a million
dollars
and this makes the ceo of cbs so angry
that he becomes
fixated on ruining janet jackson's life
he made sure that she was blacklisted
from all of the major
music video networks like mtv and vh1
and
all cbs owned radio stations now radio
stations how quaint
remember this is 2004 there's no spotify
there's no apple music
radio stations were the place where your
music got out so was mtv
remember trl anyone remember trl number
one uh closing out the week
here's larger than life the backstreet
boys on
cri come on trl carson daly
i'm getting old it's fine i thought
carson daly was pretty cool
janet jackson was cut off from all of
this the lifeblood of her career
because she was thought to have duped
the country
into her perverse sexual stunt but wait
a minute can we can we just rewatch the
video really quick
let's just like look at who did what
to whom what about this guy the guy who
actually did the thing
so here i am all these years later i'm a
big boy now and
i am a journalist i think about how
words are used to communicate
and inform the public the power of words
how we frame things
i started to dive into the reporting
from this time looking at
hundreds of major newspapers and how
they covered what happened at the super
bowl this thing that became known as
nipplegate if you do this if you really
immerse yourself
in the news of the time how it was being
discussed and especially with a little
bit of hindsight
you can really learn a lot about what
really happened here
so first off let me get this out of the
way i delved into all of the
investigations all of the evidence of
whether or not this was planned
from the fcc and the cbs and all the
people who were involved
was this an accident or was this a
publicity stunt turns out if you examine
all the evidence
it's actually impossible to ascertain a
conclusive answer on whether or not it
was planned
by janet jackson or justin timberlake or
others
you can make up your own opinion about
this but there are a few
things that i can say for certain as i
immerse myself in this stuff
number one how the incident was
characterized
now listen i like data talking about how
an incident was characterized
is hard to put into data unless you
aggregate
a bunch of news articles and look at the
language they use to talk about this
event
if you look at 200 news articles from
major newspapers that cover this event
in half of these articles justin
timberlake's involvement
is mentioned in passing it is not the
focus of the article
and even one-third of them one-third 30
percent
don't even mention justin timberlake at
all he's completely absent
from one-third of these 200 articles
sorry can we just rewind watch the video
again let me just watch it one more time
so this happened and 33 of the articles
didn't mention this guy wait what why
not
if you're a reporter and you say this
happened you should mention
who did the thing number two is the
importance of
language language language language the
words you use
the syntax you use to construct your
sentence matters and i know this i know
this for a fact
because i do this every day i sit at a
computer and i construct language
to communicate ideas so this this is my
sweet spot
and i have a lot to say i'm looking at
some of these articles from
the 2004 incident and the language that
is used to describe
what happened which again is very
important especially in a pre-visual
web video internet age the language you
use
is very important the new york times the
reputable new york times described the
incident as
janet jackson's breast bearing fiasco
another article framed this as janet
jackson
quote flashed one breast in front of the
largest television audience of the year
in the super bowl
halftime show in normal english syntax
you have an agent you have a verb and
you usually have an object something
that happens so
some person or something does verbs
something else in this case janet
jackson was the agent
she flashed her breasts in front of the
largest audience of the year
no mention of anyone else washington
post 2004
quote what janet jackson did was bizarre
deliberately flopping out of her costume
like that
the syntax the lack of any other agent
any other
actionable person in this scene that
frames this event in very clear terms
for a reader to decide who's to blame
here
a lot of this reporting turns justin
timberlake the guy who actually
pulled the breast cup off of janet
jackson's clothing
into the victim the boston globe says
that quote
justin timberlake reached over to that
infamous right breast belonging to janet
jackson
reached over to that infamous right
breast like
the breast was inherently infamous it
was just waiting
for innocent justin timberlake to like
stumble into the trap how can a breast
be infamous
can somebody like you just describe that
comment below how can a breast
be infamous these reports frame
janet jackson as the provoker
and justin timberlake as the innocent
bystander
being lured into the trap all the
emphasis was put on me
not on justin language matters i'm not
just nitpicking
like little teeny tiny words here this
is how you frame
something as a journalist reporting the
facts
is a process of deciding what language
you use and what facts you choose to
include
the language used here clearly pushes
the audience in one direction
i mean do you disagree like i i'm sorry
i i
am i being totally misinterpreting here
of this i'm trying to give the most
honest
and like generous read to all of this
and like really try to see it clearly
and this is what it says to me very very
clearly from like a data perspective
like i am looking at a lot of articles
okay our third takeaway is who
felt the fallout from this whose career
got effed up
janet jackson not justin timberlake
there was a dog
pile onto janet jackson blacklisting her
from the radio
from mtv from vh1 meanwhile justin
timberlake skirted by
basically unscathed in all of the
interviews janet is
so apologetic and ashamed and
embarrassed
while justin is sort of just like hey
man
i love giving y'all something to talk
about his career wasn't really touched
by this
even though he's the guy who did this
janet on the other hand became the most
viral thing
in internet history and i'm not just
being hyperbolic there like
this is considered the most searched
event
in the history of the internet and the
search is janet jackson
exposing her breast it's not justin
timberlake ripping off a piece of
clothing
that is not the search the search is
janet jackson
okay my last takeaway and this is the
one that like
i don't really understand and like i
want to have a better understanding of
and i'm actually left a little bit
confused which is that
humans love this stuff humans love it
our brain for some reason is predisposed
to love
and fixate and just devour this sort of
content
it's human psychology at its most basic
and predictable form
and i don't really understand why let's
remember the setting this is 2004 early
2004. it's an election year
george bush is up for election a few
months earlier
george bush and his administration had
led us into a war in iraq which
as i've covered in previous videos was
largely a war of choice
and now our taxpayer money is being used
to wage a war halfway around the world
looking for fake wmds and yet
this this half a second of an exposed
breast was
the epicenter of our attention this is
what mattered
this is what warranted discussion and
congressional hearings
and tons of conversation this woman
and her body and her behavior
i'm not trying to be the woke police
here i'm not trying to convince you of
anything other than what i
am seeing and what i'm finding as i look
at this with clear perspective
and with some understanding of how
language and media works
now that i've lived a little bit of life
if i'm missing something let me know but
let me be clear about something
this wasn't an isolated incident this
sort of biased coverage
and scrutiny wasn't new in 2004 and it
certainly didn't stop
i remember when i first started working
at vox we would have these meetings
and discussions about the youtube
comments and i was publishing stuff on
youtube i was showing my face more and
we were growing and it was exciting and
i'd love to read the comments and be
like oh look at all this
excitement around the work we're doing i
was sort of naive and confused at first
because i would put a video up and get
all these cool comments wow
this guy's just traveling the world it's
super cool and then i would read the
comments
anytime we would put up a video where a
woman
a female was the host the comments were
always so much more active and not
with discussion about the video but
about the host herself
her voice her hair her clothing i'm
married to somebody who makes videos for
the internet i see
every comment that comes in i see what
you say to her
versus what you say to me it's as
predictable as like
my children's behavior it is like a law
of nature
that the comments on her videos will
focus
so much on her touching her neck or the
voice she's using
or her interrupting me it's like so
predictable
it's like so simple almost what is it
why do we love
to shine a spotlight on women and
analyze and talk about
what they look like and how they behave
now that's almost malfunctioning isn't
[Music]
it
[Music]
by the way you smell wonderful we just
do like we just
there's just something inside of us that
does that if you're resistant to this
like i want to hear from you like what's
the counterpoint to this
i'm seeing all this stuff i'm not just
like coming up with this because this is
like cool and culturally trendy
i am seeing this in the data i am i've
seen this over
years and years of observing mass human
behavior
with tens of thousands of data points
this is my conclusion
language matters and for some reason in
our society
our language around women is very
predictably
scrutinizing and focused on behavior and
voice and appearance
that that to me is a fact that i'm
willing to just say
very clearly and the janet jackson
fiasco
isn't about whether or not it was a
conspiracy or publicity stunt you can
have your opinions on that but what's
clear to me is that
in this instance and in many other
instances it's a horribly predictable
outcome same old story and frankly i
find it
slightly embarrassing and unfortunate
that it takes me
looking through the data and reading
loads of comments
to convince me that this is real it's
almost like proof
that this is a deep part of my and
all of our psychologies okay that's all
i've got
thank you squarespace for sponsoring
this video squarespace is an all-in-one
platform where you can go
and build an online presence for
whatever you want whether it is a
portfolio or it is a shop or
it is just a personal place to have your
corner of the internet you don't need to
know code you just need to have
something to say and a desire to put it
on the internet
so they have templates they have email
marketing they have seo
they have integration with social
platforms they sort of just have it all
in this one place it's very easy to use
because they sponsor this video you can
get 10
off your first purchase whether it's a
domain name you want a custom domain or
it's hosting space so that you can host
a website and get 10
off if you go to squarespace.com johnny
harris the link is in the description if
you click that link it helps support
this channel but it also
gets you that discount okay that's all
i've got have a good day everybody
come on
heavens okay i have all these papers